Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
spoke after the arraignment saying Trump
continuously lied to cover up previous
crimes Scott McFarland was at the
courthouse yesterday he has the details
of this historic indictment
it's not just about
one payment it is three four false
statements and business records and
we're concealing criminal conduct
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
alleged former president Trump falsified
business records after planning a catch
and kill scheme to suppress negative
information about him throughout his
2016 presidential campaign according to
Bragg's statement of facts released with
the indictment Trump orchestrated hush
money payments beginning in 2015 to
three individuals those payments
included one hundred thirty thousand
dollars to former adult film star Stormy
Daniels by former Trump lawyer Michael
Cohen 150 thousand dollars to former
Playboy Playmate Karen McDougall and
another thirty thousand dollars to a
Trump Tower doorman the defendant
claimed that he was paying Michael Cohen
for Legal Services performed in 2017.
this simply was not true the indictment
lays out nearly three dozen different
business records that were allegedly
falsified the scheme violated New York
election law which makes it a crime to
conspire to promote a candidacy by
unlawful means the 130 000 wire payment
exceeded the federal campaign
contribution cap and the false
statements in Ami's books violated New
York law Ami was the Publishing Company
of the National Enquirer Bragg alleges
the head of the Tabloid David pecker was
a trump Ally who prevented negative
stories about the then candidate from
getting out it's alleged that by trying
to hide that campaign violation that
becomes a felony Scott Fredrickson is a
former Federal prosecutor in Washington
if he were convicted a low-level felony
he certainly would not in all likely to
ever go to jail over this it wouldn't
prevent him from running for president
or being president but it is certainly
consequential
keep in mind this is just part of
Trump's legal troubles he's facing
Department of Justice probes into his
connection to the January 6th attack and
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
and also an investigation into possible
obstruction regarding his handling of
sensitive material at Mar-A-Lago and in
Georgia we're waiting for the District
Attorney's next move after a special
grand jury there looked into whether
Trump and his allies tried to overturn
that State's election results John Scott
thank you